[Music]
the president of the united states has
to be ready to travel anywhere in the
world
at a moment's notice luckily this isn't
a problem
presidents today have unlimited access
to flights helicopters cars and ships
the first one in particular is air force
one known to be the most secure private
jet
in the world technically the term air
force one is used to designate any air
force aircraft that happens to be
carrying the
president but now it has come to be
identified with a specific aircraft
since 1991 the two jets have been in
service for the commander-in-chief
identical boeing 747-200b jumbo jets
bearing tail numbers 208 triple zero and
two nine triple zero
and the air force designation vc-25a
despite being america's most famous
plane not many have seen the interiors
of air force one
today we're going to take a look inside
and explore the safety and defense
features on board
that make it the most secure plane in
the world
welcome back to our channel before we
begin make sure you hit subscribe and
the bell icon
so you never miss an upload from us from
president roosevelt to now joe biden
boeing airplanes have transported u.s
presidents around the world for over 60
years
the current jets have served george bush
bill clinton
barack obama donald trump and it is now
being used by
president joe biden in the event of the
plane being used by the vice president
the plane is called air force two the
planes are based in andrews air force
base in maryland near washington dc
and are assigned the 89th airlift wing
of the air force's air mobility command
the idea to designate a specific
military aircraft to transport the u.s
president
first came up in 1943 when officials of
the united states army air forces
the predecessor to the u.s air force
became concerned that the president was
relying on commercial airlines for
travel
this of course was a huge security risk
and so an ac-87 liberator express
was reconfigured for use as a
presidential transport
but this was promptly rejected by the
secret service because of safety
concerns
the ac-54 was then refurbished for
presidential use
and given the code name sacred cow it
transported president roosevelt to the
yalta conference in february of 1945
and was then used for another two years
by president harry s truman
these two boeing planes have the same
general structure as other boeing 747s
and similar capabilities
they are almost as tall as a six-story
building and as long as a city block
each of them has a capacity for 53 611
gallons of fuel but because these can be
refueled mid-air
they can circle the globe without ever
stopping and on a full tank
it can travel half the world but unlike
other boeings these jets have their own
retractable staircases for the rear and
front entrances
the stairways open to the lower deck and
crew members and the staff
use internal staircases to access the
other floors
the plane also has its own baggage
loader so there is little dependence on
the airport for their services
which can be a security risk the planes
weigh 833
000 pounds each and are loaded with
everything a president would need for a
long-haul journey
but more on that later each plane is
fitted with four
general electric cf-6-80 c2b1
jet engines which provide 56 700 pounds
of thrust apiece
their top speeds are between 630 and 700
miles per hour
and the plane can fly at a maximum
height of 45
100 feet the jets come with 4 000 square
feet of fully customizable interior
floor space
and much of it looks like an executive
lounge in a fancy hotel
more than a plane except for all those
seat belts like any boeing the air force
one has three
decks and you can enter them through
three doors we have all seen footage and
pictures of presidents past
wave regally before ducking to enter the
plane from the front entrance
well there is reportedly another rear
entrance which is specifically for
journalists and other officials to enter
the aircraft
it takes them directly to the middle
floor where there's a press room
the room looks much like the first class
cabin in commercial airlines
with wine seats and plenty of leg room
but
everything the president needs is
located near the president's entrance
right at the front of the plane here
you'll find the president's office
which had some upgrades made to them
after the terror attacks of september
11th
so the president can address the nation
from the plane the front also contains
the president's private suite
located in the nose of the aircraft and
features a bedroom
foldable couches and a private bathroom
he also has his own workout room
most of the furniture on the plane was
handcrafted by master carpenters
you will also find the situation room
down the hall where the president can
address the nation from the skies
both boeing jets of air force one are
equipped with classified security
and state-of-the-art defense systems
including measures to protect onboard
electronics against the electromagnetic
pulse of a nuclear explosion
the upper level contains a
telecommunications room and the lower
level is a cargo hold with a
self-contained baggage handling system
the middle deck can easily accommodate
70 passengers and a crew of 26
these accommodations include seating and
work areas for media representatives and
the security staff
the crew by the way isn't your
run-of-the-mill air stewards and pilots
everyone on board has been vetted to the
highest military standards
and only then allowed to work in such
close quarters with the
commander-in-chief
it's rare to get a look inside but in
abc news did get to tour the jet and
show the world how the american
president travels
the hangar where the plane rests also
features a professional chef's kitchen
where military chefs prepare the
president's meal they ensure the safety
of the food by sourcing ingredients from
crew members who go shopping in disguise
at randomly selected grocery stores
after the food is cooked it's vacuum
sealed in the provided containers
and from there it doesn't leave the site
of the security personnel
there are two more kitchens inside the
actual aircraft where chefs prepare
gourmet meals for up to 100 people at a
time and they regularly carry
enough food to produce 2 000 meals just
in case
the plane also comes with a cabin that
can be transformed into a medical
facility
the facility includes an extensive
pharmacy loads of emergency room
equipment
and even a fold-out operating table the
plane also has a staff doctor and the
president's personal physician
before every flight this cabin is
equipped for a wide range of potential
emergencies
probably the most remarkable feature on
board is its extensive range of
electronics whose wires span
238 miles twice the amount you'll find
on
any other boeing air force one has 85
on-board telephones a collection of
two-way radios
fax machines 19 televisions and other
assorted office equipment
the phone systems are set up for normal
air-to-ground calls and everyone on the
jet can reach anyone in the world
while cruising ten thousand feet in the
air and like we said before
all these electronics have heavy
shielding that protects them from the
electromagnetic pulse that comes from
nuclear blasts
the planes are both military aircraft
designed to withstand air attacks and
other defenses include an ecm
or electronic countermeasures to jam the
enemy's radar
and the plane can eject flares to throw
heat-seeking missiles off course
the planes are maintained and operated
by the presidential airlift group which
is part of the white house military
office
the group was founded in 1944 under
president roosevelt
in 1962 president john f kennedy became
the first president to fly into jet
specifically built for presidential use
a modified boeing 707 over the years
several other jet aircraft have been
used with the first of the current
aircraft being delivered in 1990
during the administration of president
george h.w bush
now about 34 years later in 2024
we're due to get another impressive set
of boeing aircraft
which president biden will be the first
to use
the brand new 5.3 billion dollar planes
will see upgrades in defenses
furnishings and the paint job
thanks to former president trump most of
the information is classified
but we do know the new jets will have
general electric's modern jet engines
which are much more advanced than what
the current air force one jets have
these new engines will be more fuel
efficient and will save taxpayers
1.9 billion dollars in fuel while the
current jets are already
impressive we can't wait to see the new
boeing 7478i
in action what do you think let us know
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video give us a like
and check out more videos on tech on the
simply tech
channel thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time